hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar a new
approach of covid
19 surveillance testing to maximize the
identification of asymptomatic patients
i am michelle ashton of labyrinths and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinth
brought to you by via swords to learn
more visit theosorin.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during a presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send we'll answer questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
victorio sunbury
associate professor and head of the unit
of microbiology
the greater mermagna area hub laboratory
d-i-m-e-s university of bologna
victoria you may now begin your
presentation welcome
thank you thank you michelle and it's a
pleasure for me to be
here tonight and to share with the
audience
some of the newest results that we got
in my laboratory
in in italy so the
title of my talk will be a new approach
to calvin 19 surveillance testing
to maximize the identification of
asymptomatic patient
and please check my financial disclosure
these are my potential counselors of
interest and that would like to disclose
them of course
and this is the agenda of my talk of
tonight so we will start with the
some date about the epidemiology of
saskatchewan faction
giving you a global view and a more
detailed
information about what is going on in
the media romania
that is my region and in italy in
particular
we will discuss about the
necessity to make a statement about the
specimen collection type and priority
because
of course testing for covet has not the
same priority and you cannot do that
collecting the same type of specimen
and we will discuss about uh some
uh diagnostic and screening tests to
detect the kobe 19 infection and the
role
in particular and the role of antigenic
assay
and the role of morocco testing because
i believe that these two
different approaches are very different
one from another
and we need to go into a deeper
knowledge
about each one of these different
possibilities to make the laboratory
diagnosis of cognitive infection
and in particular ideas i will share at
the end of my talk the experience of my
laboratory
in the very recent use of antigenic
essay
for the screening of uh asymptomatic
subjects and of course i will try to
provide some take-home messages but that
will be
more you know a method of discussion at
the end of this talk
so let's start to give you an overview
about the kevin 19 ongoing pandemic
these are data just collected yesterday
december 15
2020 and it's impressive to know that
more than 71 million people
have been confirmed as cases of covet
19.
of course this number is an
underestimate
number because many countries are under
reporting
and there is no confirmation for cases
of suppressive kali 19
in a large part of asia and africa where
the
diagnostic resources are not so freely
and completely available
like in the western countries and um it
is also impressive to me
that more than one million and six
hundred thousand people
die about the uh diet according to the
data report by the day
who it's an impressive
thought for that and
um yeah let's move to giving two
into a more detailed information about
the countries in eu within the
the uh well it's not that's not
completely true because uk is just
leaving
eu but european country let me let me
define these
lists in this way and you see here that
we have communities cases
for each country with more than two
million cases
in in france and about the same number
of cases in uk and italy
just following a short distance by
spain with a lower number in germany
poland and turkey
and the reported cases in the last 24
hours
the data are related to yesterday
if i'm correctly remember uh
if i correctly remember so we have the
second
actually the second number of new cases
in the eu with about 18 000
cases just following uk that is just
about
18 000 cases and you see here that the
the cumulative
that it's it's impressive especially in
italy with more than 60
almost 65 000 people that die according
to the
to the uh data uh made public by our
ministry of health
and of course there is a huge impact on
our daily life
made by this ongoing pandemic
and this is just a summary of
the first pages of a very
widely read italian newspaper
that uh starts from the very beginning
at the end of february uh this is
current year in 2020
with saying italia one die
so that was the first report and it
finished with the
very last uh uh information about the
decision made by
france and germany to uh as a
more extended lockdown situation during
the christmas season and that's uh of
course
a necessity because the counting of the
people that is dying currently for
for these diseases is too high and we do
need to stop these
enormous amount of people that died
and i told you that we will discuss
about
the italian situation
and it starts february 27
uh started the case-based surveillance
system that was established and focused
on suspected and confirmed
carbon 19 severe respiratory infection
cases
the rppcr testing of nasopharyngeal
swaps
were performed at regular level to
confirm the diagnosis of all suspected
cavity 19 cages
and the cog19 infection emerged in our
country with the clustering ounce of
life
the one that the world described in
gohan china
and likewise show it worst outcome
in all their main comorbidities that was
the
highest group the largest group of
population that was
affected by severe carbon 194
the initial are with zero it was not
2.96 in lamberty that explained very
very well the high case load and
geographical spread that was
observed and at the very bottom of the
slide
just to report the very last data
we had one million and eighty eight
hundred thousand
cases a little bit more with
about eighty thousand uh healthcare
provider involved
and the main age uh for the cases was 48
yet this is a major difference with the
so-called first weight
because in the first wave we have the a
very
a the median age of the people that was
affected by carbon 19
in the first wave was by far
older more than 65 and this is an
explanation
that derived from the
misbehavior that many people young
people is having in this
time about the covered 19.
you don't see so much difference in
between the percentage of male and
female affected
and the total uh the total debt
total is more than 60 000
is the case fatality rate of about 3.4
percent
and we have a little bit less than 1
million people that
recovered and are apparently healthy
right now after the experience of kobe
19.
so it's a picture that is quite
worrying and in this slide
we report the proportion of cognitive
cages
of cog 19 notified in italy by age group
uh the data are available for the almost
total 1 million eight hundred thousand
case according you see here that the
highest
group affected is the group of age and
between fifty and fifty nine
and uh the mortality that is reported by
the
red portion of these bars is just
starting to be evident in these very
high
involved group but start to become more
relevant at least in proportion to the
total number of affected people
in the older age group and in particular
from
80 to 89. it is also note
that we have very relevant information
about the asymptomatic
and pouchy symptomatic number of people
involved it's probably
not only a causal
effect but is due to the fact
this behavior is due to the fact that
we are right now testing more
and more also people that are not
suspected cases but they are just
suspected contact of cases or potential
cases
that means that most of the activities
that we are doing right now
in the in the laboratory in italy to
control the carbon 19 pandemic
is dedicated to the detection of people
that there's no symptoms related to cog
then you see here that the
green portion of these bars that are
related to different age groups
is still very high even in the
uh lower in the lowest
case that is the age group in between 70
and 79
they total count of asymptomatic and
touchy-synthetic
people is well above 50 and it also
noteworthy to underline that the number
of critical or severe
cases is increasing again in the
oldest population starting from 60 to 69
with the peak
from as we saw before for mortality
in the age group from 80 to 89. so
there is this is epidemiological
behavior that is a little bit different
from the
the one that we saw in the first wave
because in the first wave the number of
asymptomatic people or partially
symptomatic people that we detected was
much lower but it was because this was
because of
different strategy for testing in the
first way we were just testing the
people that were
suspected or clinically suspected to
have copper 90
we are not going around trying trying to
trace the potential contact
or to trace the people that have been
potentially
have been potentially exposed to covered
19.
that's completely different right now
because almost more than
two-thirds of our activities dedicated
to concentration right now
and let's move a little bit in uh what
is our
healthcare public healthcare healthcare
organization in the region
just to give you an idea where we are
located we are in red
in in this map and we are in the
south of northern italy we are the
southernmost region of the northern
part of the country and we have a public
health organization that divide the area
in three different big macro areas
one is called area media north you see
here in
pink areva in
different shades of green and there is
romania where i'm located that
are the that is this part
in in blue and light blue okay
okay i get it and just to provide you
with this
a little bit of information about the
healthcare organization that we have in
year in romania
we have centralized the all the service
laboratory
in march 2009 and we do
anything in laboratory medicine
for the wall area of romania the
organization of my laboratory is
so-called habenspokes even if i do
prefer to call it the geographically
spread laboratory because we do have
a central heart laboratory that is
located
here in pierre sistina that is in the
geographical area
in the geographical center of the area
sorry
and we still have seven emergency
laboratories that are located
in the major uh hospital
that are decentralized they are open 24
hour
a day for seven days a week and in the
central laboratory we have the unit of
clinical pathology my unit of
microbiology and mic
and medical genetics as well the
laboratory system in romania perform
about
121 million tests per year
and the overall operating hours
are eight to six thirty month because
through saturday and on sunday we are
open from eight to
four p.m and um
again to provide you with some more
detail about the
organization of this abandon stock
laboratory
uh we had we have seven laboratories on
site the population reserve is one
million and two hundred thousand
uh but you should be aware that we are
located along the coast of the adriatic
sea and this portion of the
adriatic coast is one of the most
popular touristic spots
for summer season in italy
and in europe so during the period of
time from june the 1st to september the
3rd
along this part of the adriatic club we
have more than seven million tourists
coming in
of course they come for entertainment
and for seaside but before they can get
sick so
the the living population is one million
and two hundred thousand but
we are expecting to uh be prepared to
serve a little bit more because of these
huge
futuristic looks that we get during the
uh summer time and we have
presently about 100 sampling collection
site
on on the spots and we serve
15 different public and private
hospitals
in in in the area
okay so let's move to something more
related to
covet and we will be discussing
something about the
sample collection that we
are currently using for
the largest possible percentage of the
sample we are
getting uh into the laboratory for the
uh cavity 19 diagnostic
well it is well established that the
nasopharyngeal specimen the
nasopharyngeal secretion
collected by swab preferably a flock its
robe
when possible when available is the
preferred
sample according to the fda
recommendation as well the ecdc
recommendation so
nasopharyngeal secretion collected by
clock and swab is the
best possible specimen to make the
diagnosis of coping 19 but also nasal
swabs
provided that is a true nasal drop so
you should go
at least three to four centimeters
inside
the the nasal
district and it could be used
it's a it's a good alternative as well
it is
a good alternative also the aura
pharyngeal specimen
that can be collected whenever the
collection of
nasopharyngeal or nasal swab is not
possible according to the
patient condition or whatsoever
environmental limitation you may have
so the swaps should be placed
immediately into a sterile
transport tube that contain two to three
milliliters of
a transport medium that can be
[Music]
used to guarantee the stability
of the biological material collected in
this way
the stability should be guaranteed for
the
rna from the virus the genomic material
as well as the antigenic material
and in particular the protein that can
be used for the
detection of the antigen testing
of course the standardization of these
and and
of course you can see here that we can
have a
utm or anus transfers medium or even
theorized line it's an acceptable
transport medium provided that you keep
the
collector's rob in in the in the right
condition
of temperature and humidity and so the
standardization of the pre-analytical
steps is
now not so easy because um
we are experiencing a shortage of
collection device
and we do need to move and to organize
the laboratory workflow in order to
accommodate
many at least three presently i was just
checking this with my
co-workers early this afternoon and we
need to accommodate at least three
different type of collection tubes
into our instrumentation that is quite a
mess because you need to you know modify
the software that
manage this implementation according to
the field you are loading
and of course the
nasal pharyngeal swabs in utm or vtm
that are the universal or viral transfer
media
should be uh the preferred as i just
told you
should be the preferred collection type
and this must be done going
very deep in the nasopharyngeal cavity
it was told that the
area for the right collection should be
in the middle in between the eye and the
ear it's a very deep
collection side and
i did it myself many times
and it's totally unpleasant so i believe
that the patients are complaining about
that
and uh very understandable that they
they are complaining because this is a
very unpleasant procedure
what we have available right now for the
uh
laboratory diagnosis of uh south type 2
infection
well basically in the mind laboratory we
are currently using seven real-time pcr
because we need to
you combine a different necessity of
turnaround time personal availability
and overall laboratory organization so
we are
currently using with seven different
methods for the detection by our
rt pcr of sasko too
[Music]
and just to try to summarize the
molecular tests
uh detect of course the genetic material
from the virus
and nasal or trust is collected and
of course rt pcr is
performed with the amplification uh
after
rate of retrotranscription of rna inc
dna
and what tells you this type of test
is okay you are bearing rna from the
virus or
you are not bearing rna from the virus
that overall translated into the
clinical setting is
you are infected now or you are not
infected now
well this must be very
critically uh interpreted because the
presence of rna by itself
is not a sign of active infection
of course these are to imagine
how one can bear the rna without the
replication of the virus but you know
the exact information you get by using
this molecular testing
is you are bearing you are loading
loaded with molecule with rna from the
virus
of course you can use also antibody
testing the antibody testing can be
performed on
capillary blood or on venipuncture
and it tells you that you were affected
in the past or that you are presently
infected but it's not so easy to
set up a time frame in which you can
establish with a high level of certainty
the starting time of this infection that
means
okay antibody in an antibody test
positivity means
you you meet with the virus if you have
igm
igm you i can tell you that you are
you have been meeting device not so
not sure uh far away in the past but uh
i cannot just tell you you are still in
fact no not
if you have just igg uh the only
information we can
we can conclude is okay you have been
affected in the past and this could be
more than uh three weeks ago or four
weeks ago
and of course
uh we very recently starting from
november
that is one month ago we had
the information about the availability
of
antigenic tests performable
on instrumentation located into the
laboratory and
namely on the liaison excel and so we
decided to move also in this direction
because this kind of test
is providing additional and different
information from the molecular test
the antigenic test is um just detecting
the presence of
antigen-related protein antigenic
related protein
in the same nasal swabs collected
as for the molecular testing and
of course there is a kind of combination
to demonstrate
the presence of immunocomplex
made by the antibody that captured the
antigen and the secondary antibody that
detect the presence of the first
immunocomplex and the information that
is achievable by using this kind of test
is that you are presently infected
uh more or less the same information
that you are
you can derive from the results of the
molecular testing
uh yeah we we selected to start
to work with the uh leaves on
saskatchewan antigen
kit and you see here the the different
availability of these the different
components of this kit that are required
to perform the test on these
liaison excel instrumentation it's of
note that
the test should be
must be performed on
tubes that contain a sample inactivation
buffer
that means that once you put the
secretion
and we will see that you can collect the
secretion by using
a direct dry swab or by using the utm
or something related to utm or vtm
uh when once you put the sample in this
tube
that contains this inactivation buffer
uh the viability and the capacity to
infect the drivers is completely again
so it's
a safety measure that makes life easier
for people that need to
manage this workflow in the laboratory
well you see here the technical
specification
of the antigenic assay provided by the
assarine
so it's of note that the first time to
results
when you load the series of sample on
the liaison axle is 42 minutes so it's
quite a fast
turnaround time and the true outlook is
more than 130 tests per hour that means
about 700 test per working shift
of 8 to 12 hours so the limit of
detection
is analytical sensitivity is about 22
tcid 50 per milliliter
and the clinical sensitivity uh
is varying from 97.1
uh depending on the type of the of the
specimen this is for nasal swabs and
this is for nasopharyngeal swabs
and you see that there is no so much
difference about the
clinical specificity so according to
this data this
test is really promising because it
shows a very high level of
sensitivity and specificity so
um of course the the the first
question that raises when the uh new
test
has been uh proposed in our workflow was
okay
but how these performance performed in
comparison
with the rt pcr
so that's that's the question that also
the clinician
made to us so okay we can switch to
these antigenic
detection based tests but how can we
compare with the result that we are
getting since the last
uh nine months that are based
on rt pcr and of course the
the major uh the major issue was to
state uh to stratify the rt pcr
according to the cycle threshold or
famous ct
counts of course i'm not so in favor
of using the ct counts
as the measure of the level of rna
that is contained in the specimen
because the ct
are highly variable depending on the
target gene the probes and primers that
are used for amplification and so
is not an exact measure of the amount of
rna that you have in the sample
but anyway it's widely used so the
stratification was
performed according to different classes
of ct
less than 24 25 29 and made
more than 30 and unknown so you see here
that
the specificity is very high
on nasal swab as well is equally high
on nasopharyngeal swabs and that
even if you are dealing with the
sample that showed a ct about 30
the specificity is quite high and
there was a very few number of equivocal
samples so it's very
promising again so um
how we use how i think we
using these uh these uh
combination of uh tests that are
currently available in my
laboratory for the detection of code 19.
okay we serve
15 hospital class outpatient living in
this
area of the region we collect the sample
in patients with suspected symptoms and
we collect about
on a daily basis 6 000 sample per for
pcr
and about 1 000 samples per day
for screening of asymptomatic subject by
using the
antigenic assay based on the serene
so the second step is the third step is
of course
the transfer to the laboratory the
sample preparation
and the processing of the
sample for nat processing and we of
course
need to have a stratification of the
priority
of the sample that we manage each day
because we do need to deserve the
fastest possible test to the most
relevant
under the epidemiological or clinical
point of view
for the for the
sample that we are we are getting
so we according to the priority that we
receive from the clinton side we
stratified the sample as red coated
yellow coated or green coated
and the red coated must be reported with
a turnaround time of two hours
yellow is six hour turnaround time and
green is
within 24 hours from the arrival of the
sample in the laboratory
so we work on these different
specifications of priority
and um what are right now doing
is for for the screen surveillance of
people that
are suspected for for covet 19
infection is to collect the
nasal swabs from at the collection site
that could be either
hospital or drive-through
location in the territory and
we collect the sample we at the
beginning we were collecting the
sampling utm or vtm
tubes that are stable at 12 hours for 12
hours at 2 to 8
degrees celsius and whenever the sample
arrived
into the laboratory we started to
perform the virus inactivation steps
that is transferred the utm2 into the
inactivation buffer
and to leave two hours this activation
buffer
at room temperature in order to allow a
complete
viral inactivation and then it should be
tested
on the liaison excel well we shift we
switch it to a simpler
method that is collecting the swaps
directly into the inactivation buffer
tubes
that means the virus and activation is
just 30 minutes but it's
already performing during the transfer
of the
samples from the collection site to the
laboratory so you don't need to
sit and wait for two hours before
performing the testing after the
arrival of the tube in the laboratory
because these virus and activation
steps is already in place immediately
after the collection
and this is a very very very very
convenient uh
possibility uh who are we screening
on these surveillance pro program based
on
uh antigenic testing well basically we
are screening school
population healthcare providers
and people living in nursing zones this
is because in these
three different types of population the
screening activity is
extremely easy to be scheduled so we
know exactly
how many samples we can collect with
this limitation of about one thousand
per day that is the
upper limit that we can manage on a 24
hour shift
and so we just selected these three
different type of population school
population
people living in the nursing homes and
healthcare providers are exposed to
covered 19.
um what we do right now is
to add this new approach of uh
surveillance for covet 19 because
of course if you go for screening by rt
pcr
and you will bear in mind that we have a
priority list
the surveillance testing is fitting
exactly in the green coded series of
spreading
so we cannot perform a very fast uh
testing on green coded it's a 24 hour so
rt pcr with green code is typically
reported within
24 hours while the antigen detection
is much faster and allow
us to uh start
very soon the contract racing and to go
for you know
a deeper investigation
of positive results and at the very end
it's more efficient in stopping the
transmission of the virus
rather than using the rt pcr
so the that natural guideline that has
been
have been published on september 11th
this year are related to antigen
detection
the the use of antigen detection testing
date diagnosis
of saskatoon ii and this is mainly
related to
rapid immunisate that is the lateral
flow a group
or even the immunofluorescence group
this is not
completely appliable to the
test we are discussing now
and um
the summary of this whole guideline is
more or less this one
the target analyte is the virus nuclear
capsid protein that is preferred because
of relative abundance rather than the
s proteins the nucleocapsid protein is
much more uh released into the
upper respiratory the secretion than the
s protein uh the sample collection
material are generally
available in the commercial kit and the
results are read by the operator within
10 to 30 minutes
and it can be used as an instrument to
help the reading or
just it can just be done by you know
visual inspection of the device
uh of course these tests are uh
feasible on nasal or measure for in the
swaps
there is a huge effort by many different
companies to
use alternative sample types such as
saliva but
as as far as today
there is no combining clinical
validation of these
biological specimens for the detection
of antigen
related to carbon 19 infection
so the performance should be
sensitivity above eight percent and
they should have a very high specificity
ranging from 97 to 100 percent
and the preferred testing period for the
antigen test
is in between five to seven days
following the onset
of symptom and the shelf life of these
large majority of the tests are
in between one year to one and a half
year and the shifting temperature
is more or less in between two to thirty
temp thirty degrees
so uh of course the use of antigenic
tests
has many different possibilities
that are summarized in this glide
of course the first use possibly used to
diagnose code infection where
naat is not available
or when you need to investigate a wide
spread community transmission the engine
may be used
for early detection and for contact
reasons may that they
they provide a very rapid turnaround
time so that the concentration could be
performed in a more efficient way
uh of course the use of antigenic test
is advised
when the plunger a tat of real-time pcr
is excluding or is diminishing is
reducing the clinical
utility of the test and also for the
outbreak investigation such as the one
that we were just
describing before
which is the role of the antigenic test
the antigen
antigen test antigen based testing could
help to rapidly identify people who have
high level of virus and those who are
most likely to be infection to other and
isolate them from the community
well this graph
summarize the different
three different possibilities that uh we
uh
described it so far in this lecture this
is the period of
exposure to virus and these
brown curve is reporting the uh
rapid antigenic test uh detectability
in gray you see the detection of the rna
from the virus by rt pcr
and these two different light blue and
more dark blue
the detection of igg and that body but
it is still
unclear which is the viral load that is
the threshold below which
a person is no longer contagious this is
the question because
when you describe the test that
is capable to identify very extremely
low
number of viral or genome copies per ml
is it making sense in terms of is this
making sense in term
of uh capability to spread the infection
well i must confess are quite doubtful
about this
statement and we need to go for
uh more defined uh
scientific data so uh there are
scientific studies that report
a i would say nowadays we have
many different studies that are
reporting this type of information
that reports a strong relation between
the ct value
and the ability to recover infectious
virus in cell culture
the other life virus is reduced by 33
percent for
every one unit increase in the city
value that is a very
strong relation in general
i would say that the cutoff of ct
above 33 or 1935
is generally associated with
non-infective samples detected within
the first five to seven days following
the answer of the symptoms
and the persistent of the symptom from
mind is where it's strongly correlated
with
blundered viral rna shedding and
recovery of virus so
we do need we do need to go for
a definition of these ct
value threshold because we do need to
know
if a people that is that being detected
as positive by rt pcr is
actually infecting or is capable to
spread to shed
the virus in a in
in an amount that is capable to attract
healthy people that get in touch with
the droplets emitted by this patient
this is a question mark that we still
have but we have
some evidence uh i would say more than
one
that correlates very easily the
probability
of getting a positive result in cell
culture when when a sample is
[Music]
treated with cell culture in vitro
with the cycle threshold and according
to the
uh period of
of beginning of the disease so you see
here that the cycle threshold
is decreasing over time and
the probability to get the positive
result is higher
when you test a a patient
in the very first five days maximum
seven days
from the onset of the of the disease and
you see
here that the probability of getting a
positive
culture is decreasing over time and over
the
availability of the
cycle threshold very very low level
so that means that the pcr is the pcr
if a pcr is positive
with a ct threshold above 35 or
30 33 or 35 and
the the sample is collected after the
first five to seven days from the onset
of the disease
the probability to have a very to have a
positive
result in cell culture is extremely low
if any
so that means that we should
be able in order to control the pandemic
and describe among the asymptomatic
population to identify the people
that are in this condition we should not
care too much about the people that are
in this area of this graph
so okay there is a very nice paper just
coming out in
uh new england journal of medicine by
michael miner
and that states that
we have two different possibilities
to control the epidemic
we are currently living with
should we improve the frequency of
testing or
as an alternative should we improve the
sensitivity
of our test these are two completely
different
approaches that are summarized in these
graphs you see here
that the green the the blue curve
is the viral load over time
and you see here that if you test
these uh people by using
a test with high analytical sensitivity
like pcr but the low at the low
frequency or lower frequency because
it's not possible to perform pcr
many times in a week or many time in a
month you
you see that you can pick up this is a
positive result you can pick up
a positive result in in a positive
infectious positive
period by pcr while if you go for
a a lower sensitivity testing
by antigenic testing but you use this
test
in a very frequent way
that is possible because these tests are
less expensive or less complicated that
they are pcr
you have a very high probability to pick
up a positive result
during the infectious stage that
characterize this part of the disease so
at the very end i believe that is not so
relevant to test with a very high
sensitivity test
if you want to control the pandemia in
asymptomatic population
basically and
i'm coming to the end of my lecture and
so i want to share with you the
result that we got in the last week of
november
we tested the 6852
asymptomatic patient by using the
liaison excel antigenic testing and you
see here that
according to the dose detected uh that
the test states that if the dose is
lower than one number tcid 50 milli per
milliliter
the test is negative and you see here
that we had a huge percentage of tests
with uh 50 tcid or 75 and even
a little bit less but still a huge
proportion of
negative with 100 pcid
level these are negative these are
above 100 and 200 that
are positive so you see here that the
lower
percentage of positive tests that we got
and if it doesn't know that uh we
propose it to include
in these testing a so-called gray zone
from 100 above 100 to 200
tcib those and you see here that this
could be very useful to enlarge the
detectability of the infecting
people so uh
coming to the the results into mass
detail we had uh
[Music]
90.8 percent
of very uh of of sample that are
completely negative
with a tcid 50 per milliliter below 100
we had uh 6.7
in the area of tcid in between 100 and
150 and 0.6
in the area between 150 and 200 and
only 1.9 of
strong positive with tcid detected above
200 that's that's quite
uh relevant because uh 58
samples were in between 100 and 200
tcid that were run by rt pcr
and five of those with
nine percent is expressed in percentage
uh uh rt pcr were positive with uh ct
they were lower than 30. so we can
estimate that 45 sample out of these
more than 6 000 samples should be
positive
that correspond to 0.7 percent of the
routine work we do
and the remaining six point six percent
of being sampled between 100 and 200
should be considered as negative
so the sensitivity is very elevated even
if you consider
a a a sample a threshold of 200 is 82
but if you consider a threshold of
100 pcid 50 is a 93
and in in detail in trying to summarize
we
screened from november to
yesterday to december uh more than 13
000
individuals were tested we we got a
total of
260 positive results
by anthrogenic testing of course the
population was the one that i just
reported and described it to you
we considered that all of these 260 were
confirmed by our tpcr testing
and we got confirmation by positive pcr
in 232 cases
and we consider as a full positive
reaction
uh 20 only 28 that were
negative by pcr so the overall
specificity of the antigen test
calculated in this way
is 99.8 percent and it could be
very easy to increase the surveillance
of this population
from the present based on our tpc are
testing through 45 days to
twice a month so the
prevalence of currency positive in our
here is
1.4 percent uh according to the data we
got from the government
and uh the percentage of
positivity that we got by using the uh
antigen test which is 1.7 percent is not
so far away from the prevalence of the
currently positive
but you should consider that
of those positive reported
66 66.3 percent are
on uh are related to control swaps
and only 33.3 percent
are deriving from swaps performance for
diagnostic purposes on suspected cases
these are the two percentage in my in my
region and you see that the different
proportion of these two categories of
testing
are are very relevantly
varying from one region to another
so let's come to the conclusion i would
say that the
erratic diagnostic test that is 14
minutes is achievable by using this high
through output platform with more than
130 tests per hour
uh it's helpful to stop the kavi 19
transmission because you can target
isolation and cohorting of the most
infected cases
and they are closed counted in a very
efficient and short time after the
collection
of the sample less than a shorter time
than
if you go for rt pcr testing and you can
expand access to testing and so
guarantee higher level of traceability
and the increased frequency of testing
can also maximize the capacity to
identify
positive asymptomatic individuals so
overall i believe that these
kind of tests is a very promising and
very useful test
for helping us to control and to develop
a more efficient strategy to
stop the current pandemia of carbon 19.
and well i thank you for your attention
and i'm of course open to any question
in my head
thanks
thank you vettorio for your informative
presentation
we will now go ahead and start the q a
portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
okay let's get started our first
question is
in what situation could antigen tests
be useful well i believe that the
antigen testing are useful
potentially in all the situation in
which you need to be
very time effective
in providing the answer and you know
that means you need to have a very
reduced
turnaround time and in all the situation
in which you need to control
a large amount of population that can be
tested altogether
so provided that they have a very high
specificity and
very high sensitivity i believe that
these
kind of tests could be very helpful
in order to stop the transmission of
cavity 19
because they they allow the department
of public health to go for a more
efficiently transiting
traceability tracing activity and
so that we can enlarge the number of
people that
could be screened for the presence of
soft co2 infection
now what about convalescent patients
well i also believe that these kind of
tests
are appliable and they could be used
also to test the convolution patient
because
what we do need to know when a patient
is
exiting is finishing the carbon 19
clinical uh
picture is if these subjects
is recovering under the clinical point
of view
are still spreading uh
infecting virus and since these tests
are
less sensitive than rt pcr they have a
higher limit of detection i believe that
these tests can be very helpful not to
identify as positive people that are
spreading
the virus at the level that has been
widely demonstrated not to be infected
in
cell culture so i believe this is a very
important
field of application of this test
okay thank you what
is your what is your opinion and
experience
on saliva as a clinical sample to detect
stars kobe 2 that's a very good question
thank you
uh uh we we started to
make some uh evaluation of uh
tests performed on saliva and i could
say
that if you go for rt pcr
testing the use of saliva provides
results that are affordable as the
result that you get by the same test by
using the nasopharyngeal
swabs and secretions so
if you go for pcr there is no so much
difference in between the use of
saliva and nasopharyngeal specimen uh i
have no
wide experience on the antigenic testing
i know that there are many different
tests currently under development based
on saliva and
antigenic antigenic detection and i
believe that this could be a very good
opportunity for the future
for the near future hopefully because we
do need to identify the pre-analytical
steps in order to
make a larger cohort of people
tested for carbon 19.
okay i have one more question
for how long do you think we will
continue to perform
monitoring of sarsko v2 do you think
perhaps the middle of next year
uh yeah i'm not an epidemiologist so i
cannot provide
precise answer to this question but my
feeling that is based with discussion
with
people that is involved in the
epidemiological analysis of their data
that they have available on a daily
basis
yeah i believe that all of these huge
amounts of testing
will not decrease or stop before the
middle
of the next year so i'm expecting that
the situation could demeterate a little
bit
by beginning of the next summer but
this is just a guess or better this is
as they hope
thank you victorio do you have any final
comments for our audience
before we go today yeah if i can make a
comment
is uh is a comment that i would like to
address to my colleague virologist
is please do not stick your
idea on the necessity to have a very
high
sensitivity testing for our tpcr
because according to the discussion that
we currently on a daily basis we have
with the infectious disease especially
that with the
icu doctors and with the department of
public health doctors
i can tell you that if you use a very
sensitive rt pcr for screening purposes
i'm not talking about diagnostic
i'm talking about screening of
population i would say that you will
probably provide the data that are not
completely fitting
into the clinical needs you will be
detecting people that are
by sure positive according to the rt pcr
result but these people are likely not
to be effective
if the city are above 33 or 35 so
this is making not so much sense under
the clinical point of view this is my
comment so we need to have
you know additional testing approach
that is probably more fitting in these
clinical and epidemiological needs
that's my comment thank you
well thank you very much vittorio for
your time today
and your important research
and you would also yes thank you so much
we would also like to thank
labyrinth and our sponsor dia thorne for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their questions any questions we
did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information
be provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
and labyrinth will alert you via email
when it's available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's event
until next time goodbye